yeah I mean you've got this amazing
resource we've got great sunny weather
here in Queensland and it'd be a shame
to waste it when it
I grew up in cans and it was really
normal to you know ride her bike down to
the creek and go for a swim
just spend some time in the rainforest
when we're looking for a place to raise
the boys
I wanted something similar where they
could go out and explore it wanted a
power wall it was curious about it
I knew the you know the quality of the
Tesla car and the products we were using
quite a bit electricity with the ducted
air I thought well let's see how we can
save some money and obviously help the
environment
I knew the battery technology was good
but the form factor of the tesla
powerwall it has to look good as well
and not take up too much room it looks
futuristic they've spent the time on the
design it'll charge itself on off-peak
power midnight and tide you over in the
morning when you wouldn't be generating
solar you look at the weather forecast
for the following day and if it's going
to be overcast it'll charge itself fully
on the off-peak power so you're using
the cheapest power during the day
use a decent amount of electricity I've
done the analysis myself and we save
quite a bit I reckon we'd save between 2
and hour for three grand a year I've
always been interested in the science of
global warming even from a kid always
been conscious of it so yeah it's a good
feeling I've been telling people that
now my house runs on fresh sustainably
sourced local electrons
my name's Clint Lerner I guess you could
say my life's fully charged